a sugar seeking ant is the restaurant a
spice super slow go and like ants sweet
tooth swarm here to experience a unique
taste sensation opened in 2000 the
restaurant in Barcelona serves only
desserts but they don't come cheap
a la carte or multi course menus cost
more than 50 euros the establishment is
the first of its kind worldwide dessert
is very important because it's the grand
finale of a menu that tops off the
gastronomic experience it's the memory
the guests take home that's why we
opened a dessert restaurant spiced
Sucher means sugar space but besides
sugar recod Martinez's award-winning
creations also contain unusual
ingredients like vegetables cheese herbs
or vinegar
he likes to experiment with flavors
because according to him there are no
real rules for what constitutes our
dessert
was the CM brave in Samos Chios
we always think a desert must be sweet
but that's wrong it can be something
completely different it can neutralize
the taste after official message or add
freshness to a menu you can also disrupt
the order of courses and introduce
another say chocolate flavored dessert
and a spy Supra a single dessert can
require up to 12 different components
and preparation techniques but for Yura
max Ricard Martinez keeps it simple what
was a fatal hospital
today we're preparing a simple and
refreshing dessert you can make it for
your friends or your partner for a day
fresh and the ingredients are yoghurt
pineapple lemon foam raspberry jam and
dried hibiscus flowers make tea from the
hibiscus flowers and let it steep for 4
minutes then cut up the pineapple and
marinate it for 6 hours in the cooldown
tea he enters a Moses como le monde' now
take half a litre of lemon juice 2
tablespoons of sugar and 5 grams of soil
health food stores whisk it all together
you have lemon foam then just spread the
yogurt add some raspberry jam arrange
the pineapple pieces in the center and
add a scoop of strawberry ice cream
police comprar este lado lopez comparing
you can buy the ice cream from any
subtle marketer here we make it fresh
every day but at home I just use the one
from the shop
mi casa y ou come for another super to
cap it all off just at the lemon foam
and voila a light and simple dessert
that goes with any meal